[Music]
brilliant incredible one of my favorite
contestants I've seen this year we are
experiencing the best season ever grab
your tissues and get ready to be
entertained America's Got Talent
delivered some seriously epic
performances during Tuesday's round of
auditions
here's identical twins and master
magicians Tony and Jordyn their act
which involved literally pulling objects
and people out of thin air totally won
over the judges we are in the stairwell
and we're from the United States Air
Force Academy the military singing
groups acapella cover of a One Direction
hit blew the audience away but it was 16
year old Christian gordinho who stole
the show the singer went blind as a
child but regained his sight at 12
you
Christiaan completely captivated the
judges especially howie mandel if you
can make one wish right now this second
to make something come true for yourself
what would you wish
probably the golden bus ticket well your
wish just came true
[Applause]
[Music]
you